Super Bowl 57 was filled with memorable
moments and it was great to see
interpreters for the deaf and hearing
impaired for the first time in the NFL
but did you know that you've definitely
seen one of the interpreters before the
United States national anthem is part of
the opening of every Super Bowl this
year the Star-Spangled Banner was
performed by eight-time Grammy
award-winning country music artist Chris
Stapleton this is also the first year
that the Super Bowl has included
interpretation for the death for the
national anthem with the National
Football League bringing in American
Sign Language interpreters to relay
Francis Scott Key's well-known lyrics
sign language interpretation was also
provided for babyface's performance of
America the Beautiful and for Rihanna's
much anticipated halftime show
babyface's performance was interpreted
by University of Arizona researcher
Colin Denny a member of the Navajo
Nation who signed America the Beautiful
using a combination of ASL and North
American Indian sign language which is
still used by dozens of tribes to this
day meanwhile African-American
Philadelphia native and Bowie State
University nursing student Justina miles
provided interpretation for both
Rihanna's performance and Cheryl Lee
Rouse performance of lift every voice
and sing as for the fellow Who provided
sign language for the Star Spangled
Banner there's a good chance you may
recognize him from a variety of movies
and TV shows if you're a fan of the
Mandalorian or scrubs or just keep up
with recent Oscar winners you recognize
Troy kotzer growing up in Mesa Arizona
and Phoenix katsur was born deaf and
studied film theater and television at
gallaudet University he established a
solid career in theater and has made
appearances in several films and
television shows over the years in 2019
katzler became the first deaf actor to
act in a Star Wars production when he
appeared as a Tuscan Raider in an
episode of the Mandalorian using a
Tatooine version of sign language
what are you doing negotiating in 2022
he made history as the first deaf male
to be nominated for an Academy Award and
subsequently to win an Academy Award
concert won best supporting actor for
his performance in 2021's coda in which
he played a deaf fisherman attempting to
come to terms with his hearing
daughter's aspirations to become a
singer he appeared alongside another
history maker Marley Matlin who became
the first step person to win an Oscar
for her performance in 1986 as children
of a Lesser God despite only appearing
in one episode Troy kotzer's
contributions to the Mandalorian are
impressive both as an actor and behind
the scenes Maverick still he hasn't
received the widespread recognition he
deserves due to the fact he took on the
more unsung roles his face wasn't shown
on camera and off-camera work tends to
be overlooked in general and his
involvement helped bring a fun scene to
life the chapter 5 the Gunslinger
episode of the Mandalorian sees
articular Bounty Hunter encounter a pair
of Tuscan Raiders on Tatooine they must
negotiate with them for free passage
across their land so he communicates in
their native sign language and gets the
deal done causer plays one of the Tuscan
Raiders but he's hidden behind layers of
Prosthetics and unrecognizable as a
result khasser also helped the show's
creators come up with the Tuscan sign
language the Oscar winner was initially
brought in to help develop a new form of
sign language for the show so he turned
to Star Wars lore for inspiration as
opposed to using traditional American
sign language for example the sign for
Mandalorian was based on the shape of
the character's helmet and the M
handshape as viewers it's easy to
overlook the smaller details that go
into bringing certain scenes to life
however katsu's work actually enriched
the Tuscan Mythos of the Star Wars
universe
foreign